[Music]
good afternoon again from the MIT campus
Cambridge Massachusetts we welcome you
to the third in our sequence of MIT C
AES ILP distinguished lectures ILP is
industrial Azon program here at MIT C
AES is the Center for advanced
educational services for those of for
those of you not here presently in the
audience on the MIT campus I'm delighted
to report that it's early March and
truthfully speaking crocuses and
daffodils have shown their their sprouts
we won't discuss the weather any further
than that we are delighted to have with
us today a true icon of MIT somebody
were very proud as a member of our
faculty Institute professor Millie
dresselhaus she took time out of her
busy schedule to join us today she's an
award-winning solid-state physicist
and she's done lots of service in the
scientific area as well as being a world
distinguished acting Domitian and
researcher and teacher most recently she
adds to her long list of accomplishments
she's been named president-elect of the
triple-a s the American Association for
the Advancement of science and I guess
she joins this pretty soon within the
next several months she becomes
officially president-elect rumor has it
that if she's good at this job she then
becomes president and about here and
then after that chairman of the board of
directors in 1998 Millie dresselhaus is
the ninth woman ever to be elected to be
president of the triple is a real
distinction her leadership within that
Association reflects a desire to foster
more encouraging atmosphere for
scientists and engineers in a time of
shrinking and constrained public
resources
professor dresselhaus is a National
Medal of Science winner
whose research has helped unlock many
mysteries particularly mysteries of
carbon one of the most fundamental of
organic elements and she studied various
aspects of graphite and his author of a
newly published comprehensive source
book on fullerenes known affectionately
as bucky balls or bucky tubes in fact i
hadn't heard of bucky tubes i look
forward to learning about them today but
she's gonna show bucky balls today and
this is one of the symbols this is I
guess a smaller buckyball she also has a
larger one she's going to show us later
today that's supposed to be a joke folks
yeah her current research concerns
various carbon-based systems including
these bucky balls and nanotubes
low-dimensional thermoelectricity
magnetism high-temperature
superconductivity
she's been at MIT even longer than I
have since 1960 we don't say what I
entered but it is shortly thereafter and
she's been the member of the local
engineering department physics
department and perhaps most importantly
she likes to cite that with her husband
dr. gene F dresselhaus who's the
theoretical physicist they have four
children and three grandchildren at last
count as the count change since since we
heard about this okay Millie dresselhaus
thank you very much for joining us today
[Applause]
well I'm delighted to be here and
participate in this series it's really
important for the professor's to get out
and talk to the public including the
industrial liaison members and tell you
what we're doing that's so exciting
today I'm going to talk about these
little objects this is an object that's
probably quite familiar to most of you
many people play soccer so this is just
a soccer ball but it is also a regular
truncated icosahedron and if you imagine
that at every sixth ever if each of the
60 vertices of this object is a carbon
atom then we have the C 60 the fullerene
the smallest fullerene that we have most
common of the fullerenes
and it's seven tenths of a nanometer in
size which is very very small so that's
what we're going to talk about and I've
entitled the talk here see if we can get
the even works
new frontiers of carbon research well I
have been involved in carbon research
and now as I figure it since 1962 which
is a long time but the kind of thing
I've been involved with is very very
different from what I'm going to talk
about today which is something new and
I'd like to set to cite my collaborators
these people from around the world
who've recent collaborators on the
buckyballs and Bucky tubes and I have a
list of gene Dressel houses at the who
was introduced by Professor Larson plus
a lot of graduate students who are
currently and very recently involved
with the buckyballs of related carbon
objects that we've been studying in our
lamp
let's take a moment and think about more
traditional carbon we in in the field of
material science we always start out
with a phase diagram because that tells
you gives you some kind of scale of
what's going on this particular phase
diagram for carbon is especially
interesting one because it was the one
that was used to first synthesize
diamond 1960 so this is a very long
standing phase diagram and you you
notice that the temperature scale here
goes to very high temperature five
thousand degrees Kelvin so the scale for
a carbon is the highest the largest
scale and temperature for any of the
elements out there and on the scale and
pressure is also quite large the center
of the earth in these units of kilobytes
of pressure thousands of killer bars of
pressure so three mega bars would be the
center of the earth so we're talking
about high pressures and here we have
diamond somewhere in here with the help
of a catalyst was first synthesized in
1960 the laboratory was a great
discovery now I've spent my career
working with this object here which is
the structure and properties of graphite
which is the ground state and the
equilibrium situation for carbon and
it's the basis of an industry out there
and all of that what I mentioned on this
phase diagram was this object here I
think maybe I'll try pointing down to
the board as well for the people in the
live audience that the three-dimensional
object is as a wide gap semiconductor
that's become more and more important as
time goes on because of the very unusual
properties that all of these
carbon-based materials have there have
the highest thermal conductivity for
graphite the highest anti satrapy for
any material so they're interesting both
from a
scientific standpoint as a base material
a reference material something that we
like to talk about in the classroom to
teach students about and then we go on
from there to generate other materials
related to these often having some
stimulus and we get ideas from these
kinds of assistance well what I'm going
to talk about today is based on carbon
based on the phase diagram but has a
little different twist and this is what
we've been concerned with for the last
10 years and it has to do with a cluster
so with instead of having an infinite
array very large 10 to the 20th or so
atoms we have a very small number then
the equilibrium state is no longer the
3-dimensional or the two-dimensional
graphite that I mentioned these layered
sheets that are weakly hooked together
nor the the diamond structure but
instead we have some other structures
and why is that well the science behind
it is that in this structure you see we
have all these edge sites these edge
sites have dangling bonds those give
rise to additional energy and and that's
very unfavorable so if we have just a
few carbon atoms the equilibrium state
is not the state of a solid but is
something different and if we have a
very small number of atoms then they
form into these kinds of structures as
I'm going to show in a little while the
buckyballs and another possibility of
the Bucky tubes and I'm going to show
those in the next view graph so the low
dimensional structures which have been
recently discovered until carbons around
have been studied by people chemists
material scientists and many folks for
hundreds of years but it's only in the
last 10 years that anybody has gained
any insight into these odds small
dimensional forms of carbon so here we
have the buckyball that's c60 which is i
a soccer ball that you know and the
one-dimensional form which I'm going to
explain later which has also has
remarkable properties shown below which
is the tube and that's a one-dimensional
tube and you see that add the edges the
ends of that one end and the other end
we have half of one of these bucky balls
and in between we have a cylinder of
carbon atoms and believe it or not these
things occur in nature so we'll find out
about them and those are the remarkable
new structures and i'm going to tell you
some of the remarkable properties that
these structures have and the end of the
lecture i'll try to rush through
different things to give some time to
show you that people in industry are
probably also have will have some
interest in this in these kinds of
materials because they have promised for
all kinds of applications so so here is
carbon and just to review what i've said
we have the ground state which is
graphite that's the lowest energy state
that's the equilibrium phase and very
close and energy is diamond with twenty
millivolts above and we know that it's
almost stable its metastable because you
have a diamond ring it will last
certainly a lifetime and then then for
your grandchildren you can be quite
comfortable in your heirloom properties
the buckyballs bucky tubes are next in
energy and there in about 30 millivolts
so now why is that they're almost like
graphite that's rolled up in a tube so
the energy is almost the same but when
you make the bucky balls you see that
they have much higher energy and that's
because of the curvature of the balls so
so that's the general picture and so
with with the very small number of atoms
we gain energy by not having the edge
unpaired carbon atoms but we have high
curvature okay so let's now i have a my
secretary and putting together the leap
the poster for me in my absence
because she thought it should be more
accessible to the general public
promised that I would tell you some
other fields of interest so I said well
let's have some art and here is
Renaissance pre Renaissance painter and
in his spare time he figured out how to
assemble out of the planar objects one
of these icosahedron so this is in the
15th century and Leonardo da Vinci so
Leonardo who was a great talent in many
fields and one of the things that he did
was he made of a Bucky ball and there's
mirror writing that tells you about the
buckyball so and in more recent times
we've had buckminster fuller
here's buckminster fuller and his Bucky
ball and that's a geodesic dome and in
fact that's the reason that the
buckyball got its name was named after
buckminster fuller and then for sure it
called bucky balls so that's the origin
and you can see that how does the
curvature comes and become about well
the curvature on a Bucky ball comes
about by putting in these black
Pentagon's you probably never looked at
the at the soccer ball in this way but
the soccer ball consists of 20 hexagon
hexagon faces those are the white faces
and twelve Pentagon faces and the
Pentagon's you could see every one of
these units here with the five hexagons
and the one Pentagon in the middle
that's qu'ran Yuling which is a common
chemical molecule that has curvature and
the same curvature is that is incur
annulene is also present on this cluster
this motif and c60 so if you put these
together then you get the buckyball
so this object is of interest to all
kinds of people and I had a view graph
here to tell you it's
Interdisciplinary I'll just say
something but I won't have much time to
go through all of these but the
architects are interested Buckminster
Fuller and the astrophysicists are
interested in this because long time ago
when before the fullerenes were
discovered it was the astrophysicists
that led to the buckyballs
because of anomalies in the in the
spectra out there coming from the cosmos
and the chemists are interested sure the
chemists are interested why because here
are the bucky balls and we can append
all kinds of molecules and appendages to
them with all different properties and
many people believe that there's a whole
science out there and in technology
that's derived from fullerene derived
molecules and and solids so you could
see all kinds of phenyl groups and
oxygens and whatever here now I'll say
more about that later another thing that
you can do with these fullerenes you can
shine light on them and when you do that
they find each other and they bond in
this way so we still have the same c60
atom here and 60 carbon atoms there but
if they're properly aligned then they
come together in such a way let me
borrow professor Larson's ball here I
don't have to the same size but they
bind together and they come together in
the right orientation and they come
closer together than actually the
carbon-carbon distance on the ball and
so they form this polymerized state and
I'll tell you some applications based on
this so this is very interesting that
you can do this and it's a headache one
one hand because sometimes you want to
do optical experiments and you put on
too much light and you fry the samples
but on the other hand you can use this
to make some devices in the laboratory
well if you want to have to find out a
little bit more about Bucky balls and
and Bucky tubes so we have a new book
that's just come out from Academic Press
and expands greatly on what I'm going to
tell you here
well first I'll have some make a couple
of comments that might engage the
mathematics people in the audience know
mathematicians already know this but
this is good for kids I'd like to
explain a fundamental aspect of these
buckyballs that was essential and of
great importance in in their first
identification how do we know we have
buckyballs and it was through a specter
of course of some sort that we found
this out so what should we look for and
the Euler theorem that goes back to the
seven early 1700s tells us about this so
what does the Euler theorem say it says
here that it's given up up here it says
the number of faces F plus the number of
vertices V is equal to the number of
edges plus two and that's true for all
closed polyhedra now if the polyhedra
have the polygons of the polyhedra
happened to be Pentagon's and hexagons P
and H and that all faces F is equal to P
plus h that gives us one equation and
then the number of edges so and that's
shared up here you can see that every
time you have an edge like here it's
shared by two polygons so tui is equal
to five P plus 6h plus hexagon has six
edges of course and for the the vertices
likewise that each vertex is shared by
three polygons and the number of
vertices for the Pentagon's is five by
hexagons of six so we get then three
equations and three unknowns you solve
them together you get a remarkable
result that for the fullerenes from any
kind of fullerene composed of Pentagon's
and hexagons the number of Pentagon's is
always 12 it 12 are 12 Pentagon's are
needed to take a flat sheet and to
convert it into some closed object
that's what this theorem is saying and
if you
have a bigger polygon polyhedron the
number what happens in in making the the
bigger size is just the addition of
hexagons but the number of Pentagon's
remains the same and every time you add
a hexagon you add two carbon atoms so if
you're looking for a signature of
fullerenes you look for objects that
have an even number of carbon atoms and
in fact that was the main item main
issue main point that was used in the
initial identification so now I go back
to some historical aspects about the
identification of the fullerenes so this
is 1984 which is one year before the
first paper on the buckyballs that comes
in 1985 and we at MIT here had a PhD
student who did a an absolutely
wonderful thesis on liquid carbon and
that was not a great interest to the
practical world of industry because it's
very hard to make liquid carbon the
melting point is 4,500 degrees Kelvin
and and we could keep the carbon liquid
for only nanoseconds in time so we had
to make do quick work to to find out
about our liquid carbon anyhow one of
the things that we were able to do was
to figure out how much material left the
surface when we applied a certain amount
of energy with a laser to the surface so
we had some idea of the energy balance
and we knew that the carbon had to come
off in large chunks but at the time that
we did the work it was only known that
carbon clusters existed in very small
numbers like c2 c3 c5 s even see tens
were not very common in around that time
I visited Exxon and talked about our
work and they assured me that there were
no higher fullerenes
a higher clusters of carbon well they
pursued this work whether it was
because of our work or because of other
people's work because as you know in
science many things come together all at
once and they had the courage to go and
look for what happened at these higher
mass units
here we see a plot of the number of
species of a given type that are found
and on this axis on the x axis how many
carbon atoms are contained therein and
you could see that there's a new series
that starts up somewhere close to 40
carbon atoms and in this series each
peak is separated from each other peak
by two carbon atoms so that's a sign of
what we were talking about and there's a
very large peak much larger than its
neighbors around c60 and then a
secondary peak over here around c70 now
the people that are the Exxon group that
published this paper they were very
excited from about finding this series
and also finding a series where the
peaks the objects were all separated by
two but they had no idea that this was
related to anything new that had
anything to do with closed-shell
molecules or fullerenes or anything so
they did a wonderful piece of work but
they sort of missed the boat and science
is sometimes a little cruel that way but
the group at a Rice University they were
doing a similar experiment and they were
doing it for totally different reasons
they were trying to understand why this
spectrum from outer space that that has
to do with carbon is anomalous they had
all kinds of shifts of the spectra of
the spectral species with respect to the
spectra of carbon that we measure in the
laboratory here on earth and what forms
of carbon were out there in the cosmos
that was there with her big question so
they were looking around for this and
they also found this C 60 and they but
they went at it a different way because
they were looking for
special species that were responsible
and they postulated this creature and
because it had the N plus two sequence
they stuck their necks out and they said
it had something to do with a
closed-shell molecule they had very
little evidence beyond that it was very
flimsy evidence
well the vibrational spectra of the
fullerenes are unique and somewhat
wonderful why we have 60 carbon atoms so
we have a huge number of degrees of
freedom 60 times 3 is 180 and even if
you subtract the rotation and
translation it's still a huge number so
there are many many modes but the high
degeneracy the high symmetry makes these
modes rather special and only a very
small number of these modes are either
infrared or Raman active so if you're
doing experiments in the laboratory the
spectra are really quite simple and the
upper trace here is the infrared mode
you see four lines four big lines and
then below is the Raman spectra with ten
lines and there are 32 silent modes
that's very very unusual in molecular
spectroscopy and here we have this
situation there's another thing that's
very nice about it is that because the
system is so highly molecular it is
possible to look at higher-order
spectrum and actually yet you do
molecular spectroscopy to identify these
higher-order modes won't go into that
today like to leave some time for
applications the electronic structure is
also very unusual and could be
understood by just thinking of electrons
shared throughout the surface there are
60 carbon atoms one PI electron for each
carbon atom so we have 60 electrons to
account for 60 filled States for the
molecule and if you just assign angular
momentum
quantum numbers to this series you can
account for the angle those are
indicated by the pluses here and the
minuses are the unfilled states so that
the there's a band gap then the 60
electrons go up to here and this is
unfilled
so we get a band gap between those and
the simplest models already are able to
give the rough electronic structure of
this molecule this is really quite
remarkable and it's kind of nice for
teaching because we could give this as a
homework assignment to students and they
get great gratification with just a few
weeks of introductory quantum mechanics
they're able to explain something as
complicated as what happens the on the
electric to the electrons on a Bucky
ball okay so here is the molecular
picture and I just repeat that all the
levels are filled up to this homo level
H sub u highest occupied molecular
orbital home o stands for and then the
LUMO which is just the level above it is
the lowest unoccupied molecular orbital
so a band gap forms between the two and
we have then a semiconductor with a band
gap and then when we make a solid we
crystallized that we get a lot of
buckyballs near each other then there's
some weak interaction between them so
you get some band States yeah but the
band width is very very small compared
to the band gap that's totally different
from what we're used to semiconductor
physics like for example silicon or
gallium arsenide or something like that
so this is a kind of a different physics
and has changed in fact my way of
teaching and thinking about many things
for for student purposes well let me say
something about the condensed phase and
and they'll take the electronic
structure from a different standpoint
here is our molecule and it has 60
equivalent sites every site on the
buckyball is just like every other site
so let's look at one of these and you
see that two of the sites two of the
bonds emanating from a carbon atom are
in pentagon and they're single bonds so
one electron and this bond here is
between two hexagons so that's a double
bond so one plus one plus two is four
and that takes care of all the electrons
force for an element in column 4 of the
periodic table of course carbon is an
element and column for the periodic
table so all the bonds are satisfied you
expect this to be an insulator or
semiconductor and that's exactly what it
is but we can dope the semiconductor
just like we can dope silicon except
that we can dope this semiconductor in
many ways so here are the three common
ways the first one is we can put
something inside the icosahedron so
that's really fun and that gives rise to
something that we call an endo he drove
fullerene right now this is a year 1996
approximately 10 years a decade since
the first discovery of the buckyball
we've known about buckyballs now for
some time and we know the existence of
these endohedral fullerenes but nobody
has figured out how to produce these
endohedral fullerenes and mass
quantities and gram quantities are all
the same so we have just very flimsy
knowledge about this and this is an
emerging field maybe it'll be
interesting maybe there'll be some
interesting applications and properties
so we have many things to look forward
to as I progressed in my talk today I
will point out a whole areas of lack of
knowledge and for young students that's
always the great thing is sometimes they
come to the University I think
everything has been solved and we have
to tell them it's not so that just for
all every time we find out something
there are 10 new things that we find out
that are also interesting to pursue so
this is a fundamental thing that we
don't understand this is an object and
you can imagine a whole series of
fullerenes with additional
hexagons a little bit bigger in size but
in all of these we could put something
in the middle and make something that's
Enda he'd room with unusual properties
well we could take one of these atoms
off the one car of the carbon atoms and
substitute say a boron atom so that's
substitutional doping as is done in
silicon to make N and p-type junctions
we could do that and that's another
possibility but the most interesting
possibility is is the third one here
which is called XO he'd rule doping
where we put some guest species like an
alkali atom between the buckyballs and
an alkali metal has one electron that's
very weakly bound and that electron will
come off and we'll find its way to the
buckyball buckyballs love to have extra
electrons on them they just love that
they love to be anions and if you have a
whole bunch of these anions the electron
can hop from one buckyball to the
neighbor and do a hopping and then to
the next one and and like that you can
get conduction so the possibility of
doping these bucky balls and making
anions makes the possibility of making
conducting buckyballs well if you have
conducting buckyballs maybe you can do
even better than that and that's what
I'm trying to show on this viewgraph so
here we have the introduction of dopants
and so we have different structures here
with different numbers of dopants this
is one per unit cell and here are two
and so forth and one of them I colored
in in green here so you could see that
was special and that is three of these
electrons so we have a buckyball with
three extra electrons three anions and
with that we get the conduction band the
conduction band I can hold six electrons
three electrons fills it in half half
fills it and that gives the maximum
conductivity so for that one we in fact
get metallic conductivity so the
conductance the reason
stivity goes up with temperature that's
a sign of metallic conduction and when
we go down to low temperatures what
happens is well at some transition
temperature the resistivity goes to zero
and we get a superconductor so not only
do the buckyballs support metallic
conduction but they also support super
conductivity now this is this phenomenon
was discovered in 1991 unfortunately it
wasn't discovered in 1986 1986 was when
high TC was discovered and bucky balls
were discovered in 1985 and there was
really no reason that that high TC
superconductors couldn't have been
discovered at that time because the
transition temperature the highest
transition temperature until the year
1986 was 23 degrees and you could see
there are many bucky balls that dope
bucky balls that are have transition
temperatures well in excess of that the
highest transition temperature and bucky
balls so far is 40 degrees kelvin
however people that are in companies and
want to make a living out of
superconductors this isn't the way to go
because these are not stable
superconductors they're wonderful for a
study for a student's thesis work but
they're never going to make it who are
not for some time unless somebody has a
good idea and we can make a stable
superconductor out of these now let me
make a few comments about the bucky
tubes the bucky tubes are really
interesting and kind of remarkable and i
just say make a few comments about them
to leave some time for the applications
part of my talk so we start out with a
Bucky ball here's our Bucky ball and
let's imagine that we take the we cut
the buckyball normal to the axis that
joins these two Pentagon's okay so we
just cut like that and then we're gonna
add a whole row of carbon atoms around
the belly okay and the number of carbon
atoms that you would need to
go around the belly is exactly 10 you
look at the picture here you'll see
exactly 10 so that makes see 70 and
that's why see 70 is is stable because
it's just like see 60 with 10x extra
ring of carbon atoms and now if we put
two rings around we get to see 80 and if
we put many rings eventually we get it
to so that's what I'm going to show you
so here are the tube's examples of tubes
now this is just a Gedanken this is
fantasy
now fantasy world and I'll show you
reality in a bit so we have we can make
the tubes normal to a five-fold axis or
we could also cut the buckyball
normal to it an axis that goes through
these hexagons and that's a three-fold
axis another possibility and then we
could we have many more possibilities
but that's what I'm discussing so we
have 1/2 of a buckyball here the other
half is over there and we join those two
halves with a cylinder ok
and similarly for the bottom now let me
show you a little bit better about that
so here is the honeycomb lattice for
graphite single layer just one layer of
carbon atoms and you see over here I
have zigzag edge and what I'm do to form
the cylinder is I fold this over to make
them fit perfectly one onto the other
and you could see that they would fit
perfectly and what we have over at the
edge is something with steps and that
those steps is what we call the armchair
that's shown over here so that's our
armchair that's that and if we instead
take this sheet and we fold it this way
so we make the armchair edge superimpose
like this then what's left at the to
join up to the hemisphere of the
buckyball is this zigzag edge and that
gives us this kind of a Bucky ball
bucky - so that's how we get these in in
simplicity i'm gonna leave this out in
case i want it again why people might be
interested in these bucky tubes yes the
remarkable properties that the carbon
fibers have to which the cup bucky tubes
are related as you know carbon fiber is
the strongest and stiffest material that
we have out there
here is steel for comparison and steel
is usually considered as something quite
strong that if you pull on it it won't
break very easily or if you bend it like
this this is much what modulus means it
won't it doesn't Bend very well so it
has a high modulus but relative to steel
Bucky about carbon fibers are very much
better in the question is if you have
Bucky - how would that compare and we
thought that Bucky tubes might be the
embellishment the an example a prototype
of theoretical carbon fiber and in fact
that that's true but it has some
remarkable properties of course now that
we've been studying Bucky tubes that we
hadn't expected like science is always
that way it has a few surprises well
very shortly after people started
thinking about these tubes there was a
report literature nature magazine and
here are some tubes 67 angstroms so a
little bit less than seven nanometers in
diameter and inner diameters for this
tube this last tube here that's the
smallest inner diameter of a little over
two nanometers so very small tubes and
the length is a micron so they have a
very large aspect ratio so very
interesting now the theoretical work
that was done in our lab here at MIT and
around the world is almost all for
single wall tubes because those are the
easiest
to discuss so there was some impetus to
the experimental community to come up
with single walled nanotubes and sure
enough within a year they came up with
them so here a single walled nanotubes
and they're made with catalysts
transition metals and the bar chart
that's on the bottom of this view graph
is very interesting because it shows for
the single walled nanotubes the largest
diameters are very small they're less
than 2 nanometers
there are hardly any in this beyond 2
nanometers the maximum is about one
nanometer that's the most probable size
and the smallest size is 7 angstroms or
7/10 of a nanometer what's 7/10 of a
nanometer this thing so what it tells
you is that you have to cap these these
tubes with something otherwise you have
exposed carbon atoms on unsatisfied
bonds so that's not very favorable and
the smallest ball that you can make
fullerene you can make with Pentagon's
that are not on top of one one another
that is separated Pentagon's
is the bunk is a c60 so this is a very
special molecule it has special
properties and also defines the smallest
nanotube that you can make there so that
was very interesting discovery
in fact science is very interesting
years ago 20 years ago because this new
graph shows dates of publications that
are 20 years old people were studying
carbon fibers very a very small diameter
they call them carbon fibers they're
really nanotubes but they call them
carbon fibers because the method of
preparation is the same as what we use
today so they are carbon fibers and even
the question was asked what is the
smallest diameter that you could ever
have for carbon fiber and that was
Professor Cooper those people that are
in physics would recognize the name very
famous theoretical
physicists of the century and he wanted
to know what smoke if you have these
things what's the smallest diameter you
can have of course at that time nobody
understood the connection between the
tubes and the fullerenes so there was no
answer to that question so that's what
we really waited for for all this time
is to understand in a more microscopic
way what these smallest tubes are well
I'm going to tell you a little bit in
very short about the remarkable
electrical properties this gets into a
little bit of math and maybe the most
interesting part is what the end result
is we can in fact make a whole family of
nanotubes because all that's important
is we have to have some way of rolling
up the sheet so that the two sides can
match there are many ways to do that and
this picture on top shows the different
ways so if I go from o to a here in the
in the view graph so a point O and point
a are exactly identical they're the same
point from a crystal like
crystallographic standpoint and if I
then that's an arbitrary lattice point
there are many like like point a that's
not unique and if I now drop normals
like OB or a be prime to the line o a
then I have the lines that I have to
join so that shows you that there's a
whole family of these tubes I can make
they have a different property and that
they're chiral that is the the atoms
will wind around in spirals as they go
up the tube rather than just circles for
the simple cases that I mentioned before
but there's a whole family of them and
what's most remarkable remarkable about
these tubes is that one third of them
are metallic and two-thirds of them are
semiconducting depending on geometry so
that's a very interesting thing
I'll give you a very brief summary about
why that comes about but I can't give a
very simple display of that the argument
is based on the following concept that
when we have the tube we make the tube
like this and we have a finite number of
carbon atoms that go around the
circumference the number of wave vectors
that we would have assigned to this
system in reciprocal space those people
that understand those things is equal to
the number of atoms and if what we want
to do is as we go around the cylinder we
want our electronic wave function to be
continuous as we go around so going from
this streak sheet to the next sheet we
should have continuity so we max the
boundary conditions and that imposes
certain restrictions and what the
dispersion relations can be what it all
boils down to in the end is and I guess
that I need my next picture to show that
is here our dispersion relations with
nine atoms across the belly of the tube
this is to belly nine atoms and then the
one on the right has ten atoms that
seems almost very little difference
right but when you look at it for the
nine atom case there's a band II
generous see that is the conduction and
valence States the occupied states and
the empty states are degenerate so with
almost no additional energy an electron
can conduct so we have metallic system
and which is just like graphite which is
a good rather good conductor in this
case here
a band gap for forums and so what's the
difference well the difference has to do
with the number of wave vectors which is
totally a geometric effect on this
diagram we go this is now
reciprocal space and that we have
vertical lines for all the wave vectors
and you'll see that there are nine such
lines that are drawn here the distance
between em and the edge which is also a
gamma point which I should have
mentioned noted on on the view graph is
one-third so if the number of atoms is
divisible by three we get a metallic
state because then we'll always have a
wave vector that goes through this
endpoint which is our degeneracy point
but if we have ten ten is not divisible
by three there's no wave vector going
through that point and therefore we have
a semiconductor this is a quantum
mechanical phenomenon but it has
remarkable properties and effects on
these tubes well it's wonderful to talk
about basic science in this way but can
we demonstrate this in the laboratory
and the answer is yes and here is 1994
so it took a little while to do this
difficult experiment and this is done
with scanning tunneling microscopy and
scanning tunneling spectroscopy and we
see here the IV characteristic current
versus voltage and for a set of
different nanotubes they had a whole
bunch of nanotubes and there are three
of them that are shown in this picture
for illustration nanotubes number one
the IV characteristic goes through the
origin here straight so this is an ohmic
one so that's metallic and two and three
have a step they don't go through
straight they have a cake and the size
of from the size of this king you can
figure out what the bandgap is supposed
to be and with the scanning tunneling
microscope they can also on the same
tube you'll nanotube measure what the
diameter is so they measure the
electrical properties and the
geometrical properties all at once
that's really remarkable that you could
do that something that's as small as
this
one or two nanometers in diameter and
what they come up with is this result
that the energy gap for the
semiconducting tubules all collected
together goes as the reciprocal of the
diameter which is in that that
functional forum is what you come up
with also theoretically the experiment
did it first so they were in influenced
by the by the theory well I could tell
you many more remarkable things about
the nanotubes the fullerenes but I
thought I would say a little bit about
the practical applications in my
remaining I think I have five or six
minutes let me say a couple of things
about the nanotubes if you could have
nanotubes that are conducting and an
insulating so M is metallic and AI is
insulating you can imagine you have a
cable here the cable memory device and
put it in some kind of shell so they you
you could preserve what what information
you put in so here's a Junction metal
semiconductor Junction etc so you could
imagine different structures now this is
all nobody's made these this is just
Gedanken experiments right now we're
only at this stage of measuring with
scanning tunneling spectroscopy there is
some measurement already of transport
properties of these objects on a single
nanotube which is quite remarkable
putting so here's a single nanotube
twenty nanometers in diameter that's the
best they've done so far for leads to on
each side and of course they get
metallic conduction and it's about the
right magnitude so we're making progress
it's an interesting thing because
usually in semiconductor physics as some
people in the audience work on we deal
with planar structures and here the
metallic system is a cylinder so
re-entrance cylinder so it has some
different physical properties I'd like
to mention some other application
Nations because people industries more
interested in new materials if they have
some promise of doing some new things
let me talk about several applications
they're in our book we have many
applications we have maybe a hundred
applications but here are and we talk
about maybe 20 of them in some detail
but I've selected a few for it for today
photo transformation what is that good
for photo transformation is the
foundation of photo resists here we have
objects that are very small there are
less than one nanometer they're all the
same we can make a whole bottle of
buckyballs pretty cheap now that are all
the same and if you put light on you
hook them together when you hook them
together they no longer soluble so
there's a different solubility between
the polymerized buckyballs and those
that exist in the monomer form that
haven't been exposed to light so you can
make a pattern system and for some
applications this could be quite
interesting the use of n o I in the
process makes this quite efficient and
makes it compatible and interesting in
terms of efficiency compared to
presently use photo resists so I imagine
there could be some interest in the
applications well how does this all work
this shows the temperature range in
which the photo transformation works
well you have to be at temperature
that's high enough so that the
buckyballs will move around a bit so
that they find each other in the right
orientation but not so energetic that
they have energy to break the bond so
that's there's a temperature range where
this thing works and they you can form
bonds between these and others you can
have many bonds you can have a polymer
and that's what's shown here number of
bonds and you can detect this
with some kind of spectroscopic tool
like rahman or infrared spectroscopy
where the because the the carbon atoms
that come together are small the
distance between the carbon-carbon bond
is smaller for the photo transform once
than it is otherwise there's a different
signature there's different vibrational
frequency so you can detect them
remotely so you have an easy way to know
when you your system is working or if
it's not working and you better fix it
let me give you another example of where
buckyballs one of I like this example
silicon carbide what silicon carbide
good for it's a wide band gap
semiconductor three electron volts is
the bandgap it has some excellent
properties in terms of stability has
good mobility thermal conductivity etc
but it's almost never used because it
cannot be patterned and it cannot be
controlled very well
so you can't edge it you can't pattern
it and there aren't very good techniques
for growing nice single crystal films
but with buckyballs you can do do that
now why on this picture here I show you
a transistor textbook transistor in fact
so we have silicon that's the the dark
area and the hatched area a silicon
dioxide is the the darkened area and the
hatched area silicon that's your
transistor silicon has the property of
having many dangling bonds and that's
that's the the the nature of silicon the
silicon surface those dangling bonds
engage the buckyballs readily so bucky
balls will stick very nicely to silicon
silicon dioxide doesn't have dangling
bonds so the bucky balls do not stick to
the soviet so if you have that
transistor for example and you have a
rain of bucky balls coming on the
surface
they'll stick only where the transistor
place is and we have a silicon dioxide
is they won't stick at all so like that
you can build up a surface if you heat
up the the system the silicon and the
carbon from the buckyball will react and
make silicon carbide and you get a film
and the film is crystalline this I'll
show you in the next view graph so this
is a way and it's been done now in quite
a number of labs around the world all
right now is in universities there's no
practical device yet but I think there
could be and this shows you that it's
single crystal and here are the
reflections for a cubic silicon carbide
it has a very nice frictional property
so people that are in MEMS and micro
mechanical systems they might find this
a good system and you can prepare films
up to two thousand angstroms which is as
bad as thick as you want to go for a
device applications and there may be
other things that you can do with the
buckyballs this is one example of that
has already been done as I mentioned
earlier there are many chemistry
applications and at least in some of the
chemistry labs around the world people
are working on these there are patents
out there new materials is about half
the patents and the patent literature on
buckyballs it for new materials based on
on buckyballs
new materials derived because of
interaction with buckyballs so chemistry
is a large part of this and here you see
the polymers you see halogens oxygen and
different different species that you can
attach to these and make some
interesting systems I thought my show in
my last viewgraph something that's
stylish nowadays biochemistry people are
working hard to try to find some way of
reducing the activity of the HIV virus
and so the this picture here is the HIV
virus and then you see there's a cleft
in there the cleft in the virus is
exactly the right size of the buckyball
so if you interrupt if you send
buckyballs
raining on the HIV virus some will
attach in this place and then they will
destabilize the virus and it won't
multiply anymore so this started out as
a theory paper and then people tried it
in the laboratory and they've had some
laboratory tests with mice and it even
works so there may be some possibilities
in biochemistry for this remarkable
molecule so I think my time is just
about over and there's good time to stop
and ask for questions
[Applause]
and once the first one yes sort of three
questions to baby the saying well let's
try with one and then we'll give
somebody else a chance like you
mentioned in Memphis you mentioned metal
semiconductor transitions you didn't
mention the word insulator can any of
the Bucky structure to be insulators
well they could be insulators but one of
the problems with with buckyballs that
makes well if you have a buckyball
surface that's out exposed to oxygen it
will have a very high resistivity if the
buckyballs are very clean and pure then
the resistivity goes down so for the
practical device if you want to have a
good insulator I suppose you could say
that a surface will be insulating it I
wouldn't be out selling this for my best
world's best insulator but in principle
it has a band gap of 1.5 evey breakdown
voltage I'm not sure that we know
exactly what it is it's not very high no
no the reason why the superconductor
lated today the reason why the
superconductors are unstable is that
every single dopant that has been
successfully used to make a
superconducting fullerene is chemically
unstable that is you leave it in the
atmosphere the reagent that you've added
to like you have an alkali metal you add
that to a fullerene you leave it out in
the air the alkali metal leaves it
oxidizes immediately upon exposure to
air so that's that's not to keep the
superconductor superconducting you have
to encapsulate them and that makes the
material not very practical for
commercial applications that's a quite a
different story from the dielectric
properties
and another question yes there's a lot
of activity maybe it it interferes
somewhat with the literature because
some of the best ideas probably are
under patent and so they they're not
published in the open literature
immediately so that's that's one thing
especially in the area of chemistry and
new materials some some of the active
areas are diamond synthesis there are
quite a number of patents odd that is
here this is a curved surface the
diamond differs from graphite graphite
planar diamond has spq bonding so when
you get a curved surface you have some
admixture of spq bonding so by having
this curvature built in here it is
thought that it would promote in some
way formation of diamond and in fact it
does and people have used this as a
source for clusters carbon clusters that
are used in in the diamonds in film
synthesis and it works very well and
produces a kind of diamond that has very
small grains which means that you have a
nano crystalline size so that the
surface doesn't have so much friction as
the usual diamond surface that is
produced by present-day techniques so
for some applications you imagine a
stylus going along a surface to have non
bumpy surfaces a
Vantage so there's some people that are
pushing that the improving the
technology trying to make it competitive
in cost and reproducibility so that's I
don't know how close to
commercialization it is but there's a
lot of activity worldwide in that area
but there are there are just many four
sensors and just many different things
nanotechnology there's just a whole
range of different applications I have a
listing of all the different patent
areas in the book you're interested
whether any of these structures may be
speculative as to as far as I'm aware
the answer to that is no and speculate
may be why that's true why why haven't
they arisen as structures that you see
[Music]
in the biological world we see some
structures related to the two buckyballs
but we don't see buckyballs themselves
in fact an astrophysics people have now
been searching for it now that they know
the existence of buckyballs they have
been searching religiously to try to
reconcile the various spectra that we
find here on earth from these whole
menagerie of fullerenes and not there is
no correspondence yet there's no
verification that the anomalies in space
are really associated with these objects
so in some sense the unknown still
remains with us this has been an active
research area since 1920 some time like
that so it's many many years and when
buckyballs were discovered they thought
aha well i we have the answer but it's
still not certain that there's much
connection between the anomalies and
astrophysics and and the ball's now
getting back to the biological systems
which is what you asked about there are
many
viruses that have this kind of shape but
they're not only fuller they are not
only carbon they have other things study
of these is interesting for the
biologists because of the similarities
of the structure and perhaps they can
learn something but this itself is not
known to exist but but it is believed
that this is benign in the body that is
if you swallow some buckyballs it's not
going to kill you there has been
research and this is important for
researchers you know that you work on
some new chemical and it's it's okay
the tubes are another matter if you look
in biological works there is a lot of
evidence for very narrow tubules and
what they have seems somehow to be
related although nobody has yet made the
connection but there seems to be some
correspondence to me anyway looking at
the two kinds of pictures of what I know
that we have in in the in the inanimate
world and what I see on my biology
friends there are a lot of tubes that
that join different things and it
functions and and so forth if we
understand these nanotubes I think we
could be quite helpful to the biology
people that are trying to understand
these structures that exist in living
systems but they're not only carbon are
very long
20 football mattad - no one of course
done it wonder is there a theoretical
reason why we couldn't have reels of the
stuff kilometres or something
interesting well with carbon fibers
which are a little bit larger in size
you can make meter long lengths I think
has been for something that's about one
micron in diameter that that has been
demonstrated with the nanotubes it
nobody has been working on that
particular aspect the main thing with
the nanotubes is the lack of control is
that one knows how to make nanotubes you
can always make nanotubes reliably but
you take what you get and you don't have
real control about what the diameter is
going to be what is the length what is
the chirality and this is future
research are quite remarkable and
interesting and have real possibilities
for applications why is that it has to
do with the fact that you have a
molecular solid that's number one the
valence and conduction band have the
same parity and because of that
dipole transitions are forbidden okay so
that at the absorption edge you have to
do things to make that transition take
place so that means that you can control
it how if you can by some means get
electrons in the excited state then they
couldn't more easily make transitions to
higher states because then you can have
allowed transitions well what that
allows you to then achieve is a
metastable state for the lowest state in
the conduction band so that becomes
metastable and therefore becomes a way
to get saturation in in absorption so
that is the basis of of an optical
limiter which works much better than any
other material in terms of efficiency
and at the appropriate wavelength so
that's one application that probably
will find some use in soon just because
it works so well but there are many
other optical properties most of the
optical properties are not not so well
understood because the polymerization
effect that I mentioned has been in the
way of serious studies when people
haven't realized that that when they put
light on the samples they're making
photo transform material so which lowers
the symmetry and therefore changes many
things so once you understand that you
can work around and work at a higher
temperature or do something to break
those polymerized bonds and and you know
when that takes place then we'll know
much more about the optical properties
in detail that's the one area that's not
well understood right now about the the
buckyballs
[Applause]